all right this morning Sam text me a
great idea he goes let's go back through
the archive let's find things that we
predicted or opin strong opinions that
we had at the time and let's bring them
back up let's see did we get them right
did we get them wrong what did we get
right what did we get wrong and what
could we learn from it and so we're
going to go back Nobody Does this by the
way everyone loves to make predictions
and have opinions and nobody ever goes
back unless they were right well we're
going to show you where we were wrong on
a bunch of these we did seven or eight
of these that um we had a strong opinion
couple years ago and now they've played
out and we can review how we did and at
the end we make two new predictions so
two new things that things that have our
spidey sense tickling things that feel
like they could be big opportunities
that we're going to plant our flag and
say look I think this is the this is one
of the new ones and we'll see in two
years if we're right or wrong that's at
the end of the episode all right
enjoy all right we're live what are you
drinking uh this is my secret sauce
right now I'm not telling people about
this yet water nope you see from the
color it's a little different uh green
water I just doing some experiments you
know I thought um you know we had this
we had Derek from more plates more dates
on and he was talking about pre-workout
right he created gorilla mine that
supplement and then we talked about
bucked up and they are a pre-workout
supplement and basically it's like
people take a scoop of something before
they go do their workout so that they
get a way better pump and it just really
like sort of dilates their you know
vasil dilation and it gets them to have
a better workout I want that for work I
want pre-workout for work and so I am uh
experimenting with some things that will
how do I have like a boost of boost of
focus a boost of
productivity yeah caffeine I think it's
called but that's okay you not caffeine
caffeine is for for M morals let me um
let me ask you a quick question all
right by the way today's episode's going
to be exciting so we're going to
actually to go over some of the
predictions that we've made both right
and wrong since the Pod started a lot of
these predictions are to come from the
2020 era we're going to look back we're
going to call it what did you say the I
told you episode I told you so I told
you so but it is also going to be I told
you we are stupid and we get things
wrong as well I Told You So and sorry I
told you that because I might have been
wrong right but I got but I definitely
told you I definitely told you I just
want you to take your right hand I want
you to put right hand in the air real
quick and I want you to reach back and
let's give ourselves a little pat on the
back here why not because our
predictions were so great but because
we're actually re revisiting predictions
because predictions are one of these
things that people love to do they love
to people love to spout random opinions
about stuff and then they just go they
just it just all gets washed away in the
noise of social media rarely do people
ever go back and when they do go back
it's only for one reason when they were
right nobody ever goes back and says you
know what what nobody asked but hey I
just want to tell you I think I was
wrong about about that one or I was at
least half wrong about that one and uh
that's not the code we live by not here
not us and so we're going back nobody
asked us to do this we're going back and
we're revisiting some of the [__] we
said and we're trying to figure out were
we right were we wrong or something in
between and uh we have a a handful of
these that we're going to go back and
these are like you said two three years
ago so they've had time to bake and uh
we'll see how they not much time but a
little bit of time and the thing about
predictions is I was uh you know there's
a lot of crazy stuff going on in the
world right now and I was curious I was
like you know you and I have been having
this discussion a little bit off the Pod
about like where do you invest your
money if you think the world's going to
end like part thought exercise part like
things are crazy and I was looking at
like a lot of really smart people smart
money people Bill Amman Ray doio you
cited Ray doio you well Ray said this am
I reply to you was yeah but he's been
wrong about X Y and Z and I had to go
and dive deep about where they were
wrong cuz if you just read the Wikipedia
page you see when they are right like
Bill Amman was right about all these
things was like oh but he actually lost
a ton of money on this thing predictions
are challenging uh because not only are
they hard to make but the people who get
right G get them right a bunch of times
are also wrong a ton of times so it's
really challenging to know who to listen
to It's like a batting average right
like you can bat if you bat 300 you know
like I don't follow baseball anymore but
I think you're like an Allstar and that
means you know you're missing two out of
three right you are you're you're not
hitting on two out of three predictions
are way way way worse than that right
like if you're predicting correctly on 5
to 10% of your predictions but you're
right in a big way meaning you're
non-consensus so you're bet you're right
about something that a lot of other
people are wrong about then you make it
big which is one of my one of my
favorite quotes I said this on the Chris
Williamson pod pessimists get to be
right and Optimist get to be rich and so
one thing we'll see when we go through
these I think is that the times where we
said ah it's not going to work those are
the ones where we have a higher hit rate
right because pessimists naturally get
to be right more often however the money
is made when you're an optimist about
something that other people are
pessimistic about or as my father once
told me hey even a blind squirrel will
find a nut once in a
while so I love that by the way speaking
of nuts and seeds let me tell you about
this first one so a few years ago I was
interested in freezing sperm
the reason I was interested in freezing
sperm is because we don't need to know
but okay no listen men's men's's sperm
count is going down like a crazy amount
remember Ben our old producer Ben had
this big thread on Twitter where he was
like he documented sperm count and he
like made some Jurassic prediction that
like in 50 years like very small
percentage of men are actually going to
be able to uh procreate and this is
actually a really big deal and so I've
been I've been resear I've been
interested in that topic for a minute
and so I tried freezing my sperm and I
actually re re looked at the episode
that we talked about it and the episode
was Sam's unboxing of his of his sperm
kit or something like that yeah cuz you
had it you like held it up dude here's
the story I so like you have to like you
know you have to like get the sample
first of all to do it at a hospital
which I also did you have to bring the
specimen 30 minutes after capturing it
so like if you're not close to a
hospital I don't know what you do you go
in the room you go in the parking lot I
don't know it's like a really weird
thing to collect and it's a very
shameful thing to hand a special parking
area there's a covered parking area you
could pull into it's a very shameful
thing like when you walk into the doctor
and drop the bag it's way have you ever
given pee it's like that's kind of
shameful giving sperm is is way worse
and so I I'm always making excuses I'm
like I just didn't have a lot of water
today um and they're like we don't need
to know I'm like I captured the specimen
though yeah it's a very shameful thing
to do um and I uh so anyway I tried one
of these at home services and I brought
it to my office cuz you have to you have
to do it and then you have to
refrigerator and then you have to mail
it in and I like packed it in a box
within a box so no one even knew but I
didn't have I had to do it at at
lunchtime and people in my office were
like what's in that what's that in the
refrigerator what's this box and I was
like oh it's it's just a it's just a
thing it's a thing but it says like it
says it's like a biohazard or something
on there and then eventually someone
like was like all right what is this and
I'm like it's my sperm and uh they got
my employees got really angry at me and
they like told HR and I was like I I
don't know what you want me to do man I
just this is what I had to do so so
that's like a funny update but I was
using I tried two Services one was
called Legacy one was called Daddy D A
di at the time Legacy had raised uh $1.5
million and uh the update on them is
they've since raised uh a round of 3.5 a
round of 15 million a round of 25
million so what's that that's a $45
million they've raised so I presume
things are going well with them so the
most recent round was in 2022 daddy the
company that I talked about at that
point it's it's kind of a weird name I
don't even like saying that uh they had
only raised that out yeah yeah it's
weird man so that company has since been
acquired they're bought in 2022 for $100
million so that is a thing that we we
nailed I think uh and I think you almost
had back-to-back episodes cuz you also
were talking about uh
trt uh we said D Toc trt I think we were
like six six letters if you want to make
$100 million D to C trt and we were both
like that's a great idea and I thought
you were going to start that company cuz
I was like this is Gen a fantastic idea
you researched it and I was like you're
kind of Shameless enough to go do that
but you didn't do it but you did
introduce me to the company that was
doing it I think and we both invested in
and we both invested and it's doing
fantastic a company called hone and um
they've gone I mean they're Gang Busters
every one of their updates is fantastic
so yeah I think I think that was a that
was a right prediction I would say and
those were both off the beaten path I
don't think a whole lot of entrepreneurs
were were thinking about capturing the
specimen so to speak and uh you were and
that it paid off I think I invested at a
10 or $15 million valuation I don't
actually I haven't read their updates
because I think got sent to my old email
if you're listening to this hone update
my email but uh I imagine that business
is worth nine figures I would think I
think it's worth 10 times invested in it
um so anyway that's a that that's an
interesting one trt and um uh sperm
collection yeah that those are those are
correct I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of syn spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow
better let's do one one that was maybe
incorrect so we were bullish on I don't
know if we were bullish but we were very
fascinated on bit clout another thing
that we are fascinated is I remember the
day you told me about what an nft was
when you explained it to me I thought it
was awesome you're like I just bought
this Kobe thing this Kobe card and I was
like all right that's kind of cool and
then it things the world went a little B
the art for that one was actually
amazing which is like it was it was
genuinely beautiful to look at whereas
like nfts then became like I got this
rock I have the squiggle and it was like
oh okay you know like you're trying to
make a buck only there is no like art
aspect to this and I think you paid
$500 I think I we paid $700 or something
like that and then we flipped it for
$10,000 like I don't know 30 days later
it was actually credit to Ben so Ben was
the one who got us talking to a bunch of
nft guys early on and um you know the
right move would have been to just go
like go crazy on it for a while or
invest in the companies behind it but I
saw that this artist I really like boss
logic was doing one and the Kobe one
looked great I bought it and then when I
saw a seller it for 10,000 I was like I
mean it doesn't look that great like
I'll sell it to this guy and I can still
look at it whenever I
want so I was out of there the other
thing we talked about was bit clout so
Mar episode 164 March 26
2021 I said I signed up to this thing
called bit clout because my friend Ryan
Ryan bigelman called me and he said this
thing looks cool let's try it um and so
we both you and I both signed up for it
it was all the rage for a minute so Ryan
was on that episode so he he kind of was
pitching it he called us before told us
to to get on and then he pitched it to
us on the episode so what did he say so
bit clout by the way it's basically a
social it was basically Twitter but
there was a crypto component where you
could buy into someone's right you don't
just follow Sam you basically buy some
of the Sam coin and if Sam is going to
get more popular other people are going
to buy the Sam coin as well because
that's how you kind of subscribe or
follow the person and so you could kind
of we've all had this moment where you
see somebody early on you're like oh man
this person's awesome they're going to
get big and bitcloud was organized such
that you could do that and it also had
almost like because of that it had a
patreon built in it's like oh I already
have all these kind of paying
shareholders I could just create content
just for them only if you own x amount
of my coin you get to access this
content which is what only fans and then
the Twitter blue subscribers and patreon
they all do a version of this so it was
like aked in from the start versus
usually those are third party services
and it was a service it was one of the
very few crypto things I actually
thought was interesting you said uh you
said I think you were saying it's
interesting because let's do the Ryan
one first so Ryan goes I remember when
Facebook came to my college and we were
one of the first colleges it was really
fun this is the first time I felt like
that in a long time that's why I wanted
to come on the show and then you jumped
in you were like yeah two big
differences though one you didn't have
to have money on Facebook you just you
know you just go use it um and two like
you're putting money into this thing
that we don't know the people behind
this we don't know who who how it's
working like it's a little nerve
nerve-wrecking and you don't and there
was no withdraw button at the time you
could even withdraw money from it you're
like hey red flag money can only go in
and it can't come out and then we were
like nah don't worry about all that bro
like Downer over here and and I said
here's my quote I don't know is this a I
don't know if this is a scam it kind of
scammy to me and then I had found out
who's behind it they were Anonymous at
the time but I had found out who was
behind it by asking around I said I do
know the founders they're legit people
in the tech scene and they do have a
reputation in our circles and they had
they had raised I don't know hundreds of
millions of dollars from Andre and
horrorwitz and others like but and we
had the founder on later we had the
founder on and then and I said you know
and what I liked about it I was like you
know today um if I sell on Amazon I keep
70% of of what I of the value I'm
creating being a merchant on Amazon if I
stream on on on YouTube I'm keeping you
know 70% of what I what I um actually
not 70% more like it's like a 60/40
split of the of the ad Revenue um twitch
is you know roughly 50% then you go down
to like Facebook Instagram Twitter and
the users at the time captured zero like
those were multi multi multi
multi-billion dollar companies that the
users who created all of the content and
consumed all of the content the users
did all of the work to create the value
of the network we're getting nothing and
I said well it does seem like crypto is
kind of cool cuz it can it can change
that it can basically reward the people
who do the work who create the content
on the on these networks um and the
second thing is we loved the growth hack
so what they had done was they took all
the popular Twitter people and they just
pre-bought a bunch of their coins so
when I joined I think there was like
$75,000 of value for me to just go claim
and I was like hm okay uh push I'll push
that button let's see what happens and
uh and so they had used the money they
raised to buy up popular people's coins
and then to to claim your coins you had
to be like sign up for your account and
tweet out hey I'm verifying my bit clout
and that was kind of going viral for a
bit and that mechanic worked until it
didn't work and bitcloud failed and we
know several people personally daresh
and a few others that invested millions
of
publicly into
bitcloud and that one and so you know
smart people were doing it it was an
interesting idea ultimately that idea
failed and so I would say you know we
were excit I was more excited about it
than you for sure um you were like
immediately I think we were pretty much
out correct well I I I was out but I
liked the idea of it the idea of it was
actually fairly interesting I like the
free money yeah well no like Twitter
ended up doing it where they just like
gave you money so I get paid I I think
$3,000 a year it's on track for $3,000 a
year for tweeting and like getting
Impressions that's cool but you didn't
need the crypto component of it no but
that's different you got you get paid a
share of AD Revenue me for following you
um early on kind of being one of your
early early Believers for retweeting
your content for all that stuff I
couldn't I couldn't benefit from that
right but the same outcome for me as as
the Creator I get like I feel a little
bit more bought in well well no cuz like
what was your last Twitter check $50 uh
whatever 3,000 divid 12 is $300 maybe
something like that $400 maybe so let's
say you made $400 bit clout early on
when it had I don't know 50,000 users or
something like that yeah, my account was
worth $750,000 like you know I could
have I could have literally pushed the
button and cashed that out if I had I
cashed out a little bit of it someone
bought a bunch from someone's like hey
I'll give you ethereum for all this and
I was like yours I sold
it so some someone the funny thing do
you know there's a new one that's
basically the same model and it's
crushing right now friends in Tech or
something friend Tech yeah I'm not on it
right now just because I have been busy
with other stuff but it's I mean it's
generated like 250 million in Revenue as
a as a for the project itself and I
think it's distributed the equal amount
to to uh or people have generated that
much on it as well so then it sounds
like bit clout well let's do an update
on bitcloud but it sounds like we are
wrong about bit clout and that it bit
clout didn't work the idea did work in
friend Tech right I think I would bet
that in the long Horizon let's call it
20 years
um these networks will be built in with
these networks will will do this they
will have a currency for the users on
the network and so the users will the
users who contribute to the network will
own and control the the network I do
believe that that's going to be true
frch I think is like another kind of
like attempt I don't think it's probably
the one um but I do think over the Long
Haul somebody will do that so where's
bit clout now um they changed this thing
called do I think right the yeah they're
doing a bunch of stuff I don't I haven't
kept up with it but yeah bit Cloud they
were like oh that was just one app on
top of the dies protocol and then the
dies protocol had like many apps the
diamond app and this app um I don't
think any the honest truth is I don't
think any of it's gotten off the ground
in a in a meaningful way all right pick
a winner or pick don't don't pick a
winner pick an interesting one okay an
interesting one okay clout kitchens so
um
way back we did an episode let me find
the I think we were talking about my
cookie dealer and a bunch of other uh no
you weren't there so I came over to your
office to record one day you couldn't
make it for whatever reason and you were
like oh my buddy Stu who had been kind
of listening to some episode steu
Iverson uh was there and he was like
I'll jump in and he jumped in and he had
a bunch of ideas one of the ideas he had
was he he goes um you know how Travis
colanic has left Uber and he's got this
idea of cloud so he's like you know I'm
going to create these restaurants that
are just built for Uber Eats built for
door Dash and they'll be delivery only
there's no physical location blah blah
blah he goes well there's a better I
have another idea clout kitchens and I
was like clout kitchen what do you mean
he he goes like you know social media
guys who have clout you know they have
this like you know they have a big
influence he's like I think they're
going to open up their own restaurant
just like you know there's
Margaritaville and there's Gordon Ramsay
has his restaurants or whatever you're
going to see celebrities create their
own restaurant Brands uh they're just
going to license their name and face to
somebody and then fast forward like I
don't know a year year and a half Mr
Beast Berger comes out and Mr Beast one
of the biggest social influencers
launches his own virtual restaurant
chain exactly as th had predicted and at
the beginning it looks great because the
launch is insane there's videos of
people just like going and trying to to
order this stuff and I think it did over
a 100 million in sort of grow gross
revenue um you know just sort of
purchases of uh from from beatburger in
year one in year one and so it looked
like at the time damn St called it great
idea however clout kitchens thing has a
couple of issues one is uh you really
hard to control quality why why because
the way these work are there's just Mom
and Pop restaurants and they send the
packaging to them they're like hey if an
order comes in that's in your area
you're going to make a burger just make
whatever burer you normally make just
try to make a good burger a good
cheeseburger but wrap it up in this
Beast Burger packaging and put it over
here the guy's going to come pick it up
and that's how Cloud kitchens work it
just gives existing restaurants extra
order flow but because of that you have
total like no control over quality
because you have you know 400 operators
each making a different recipe each with
a different uh you know sort of quality
control around this and at some point Mr
Beast was like you dude this is actually
bad for my brand people are ordering
it's like not not right it's not good
whatever I need to distance myself for
this and now they're in a lawsuit with
each other because they're like nope you
signed you signed your rights to to us
we're going to keep calling it this and
you're hurting our business by saying
that and so now he can't really talk
about it so that's not a failure I mean
it's a failure for him poor execution
but it it could work you know it just so
happened he was the biggest you know at
the time or still is and it got too big
too fast that doesn't mean it's a bad a
bad concept and I still think if
someone's going to do this you could do
this you just need to like um have a
much more controlled skew so somebody
needs to do it with like just like I
don't know cookies or they need to do it
with a um like they need to do like you
know uh what's it called the Edible Eats
Edible Arrangements or whatever it's
like uh here's a gift you can send
somebody it's like you know you need
some celebrity who's going to just like
create the version of Edible
Arrangements on top of door Dash or
whatever just like this gifting thing uh
that's like can be more consistent so
maybe you could just send the final
thing to each location I think Reed told
us on the Pod when they launched Beast
bger he was like me and Jimmy were just
like in a bedroom we threw it together
in 90 days like he made it sound like
pretty ragtag like it was just like oh
let's just throw it out there and see
what happens I don't I don't know if
that's the truth that's the kind of the
energy that was implied and uh you know
so it just didn't work out for execution
reasons but it could still happen um
okay here's one that we were uh okay
I'll give you two that I was right but
pessimistic about so um Clubhouse so I
wrote a Twitter thread that was kind of
like the thing that blew up my Twitter
for a while I wrote a Twitter thread
that basically was telling people why
like Clubhouse was the hot name at the
time it was it went from like nobody was
on it to the cool kids are on it to this
is you know A2 billion doll company all
the course of like a you know less than
a year right this thing was just like
flying and it was like oh this is the
next social network and all the big
names were Believers in this thing I
remember uh I remember being like I
enjoyed being on it but I was like oh
this is not going to work for certain
reasons and then I would hear really
smart people you know Mark Andre invest
in this thing Andrew Chen you know the
social guy oh he's investing in this
thing then you hear nval who's an
investor in it and he's like um this
will be bigger than Twitter and then uh
you know sahill from gumroad I remember
listening to him on a clubhouse thing
and he's like um Clubhouse will be
bigger than Twitter because everybody
can speak and not everybody can write
and I was like that's not how this works
you can't just be like uh my app it's
called breathe and everybody breathes so
I'm going to be the most valuable
company like I was like what is this
logic and I wrote This Thread I said hey
everybody thinks CL going be the next
big thing I think it's going to fail and
here's how I think it goes down I wrote
This Thread the thread goes viral yeah
you had like celebrities reach out isn't
that how you met uh hust minhaj and who
else yeah I think so uh there was a
bunch of people that were like you know
I don't want to I don't want to like
name drop you know what I mean but like
yeah it was it was crazy it was people
that I admired yeah it was like your
Heroes I don't I mean like like some of
these podcast the sports podcast uh guys
people who were famous you know authors
or or writers or whatever either
followed or DM being like that's that
was so so good so I was like wow that
was great but I also got blocked by a
bunch of VCS who were in Mark Andre
blocks me they're like you know you know
they go from following to blocking like
instantaneously why cuz I like you know
told them that maybe their investment
wouldn't work out and um and I got some
hate some people were like oh why you
rooting for a startup to fail I didn't
say I'm rooting for it I you actually in
the thing you said I don't want them to
fail I just have experience in this
space and it doesn't I don't think it's
going to turn out nicely yeah but I
think rightfully so people don't believe
that where it's like look I wish you the
best they say that like when they're
fighting like look I wish you good luck
and it's like no you don't but I think
you know fast forward I don't know when
that was I think that was 2021 so fast
forward two years now and uh I feel like
not just was I right that Clubhouse
failed step by step because I was like
this is what they're going to do they're
going to realize that this doesn't like
that they can't grow the thing this way
they're going to then launch a recording
feature because they're going to say ah
you're missing the live show just record
it we're going to optimize towards
people creating shows versus people just
hanging out and they're going to try
recording and then no one's going to
watch the recordings and then here's
what they're going to do they're going
to be like we looked at the data and
actually yeah people don't watch these
recordings cuz the what makes the great
live show isn't as good in it isn't a
well-edited recording um so then they're
going to be like you know who really
uses this people who hang out and make
friends on this and we're going to
switch to a hangout product and sure
enough they switched to a hangout
product and they did basically each of
the steps except for the last one which
I predicted was like you know they end
up sort of fire selling it to Facebook
for you know whatever $70 million and
then he becomes a product manager of
Facebook like you know that part hasn't
hasn't happened yet um but pretty much
step by step so that one was was a right
but pessimistic and uh you know I guess
one takeaway is doesn't really matter to
be right when it's pessimistic there
nothing really that great comes of it
you know you kind of look like an
[__] even if you're right yeah
exactly I'm like and I'm like oh great
now I'm like yeah I told you they would
fail it's like oh
okay speaking of uh things that you say
that you don't really mean did I tell
you about that time that a kid flew in
from England no what one time when the
hustle was getting started this kid
called me from England he goes I love
the hustle and I was like all right
let's talk I start talking to him and we
just [__] at the end I go yeah if
you're ever in SF just let me know and
and we'll help you out and I meant it as
like a way to end the conversation and I
learned that moment you should never say
that I get a message 3 weeks later and
he goes hey Sam it's the guy from
England um so my flight lands my flight
lands tomorrow and he just shows up and
and we have hustle con like my big event
and we make him work the whole event and
we're like here you could sleep on our
couch and we dress him up in a Texas
outfit he had never been to America
before we gave him cowboy boots and a
hat that we had in an office and we
called him Texas Sam the whole weekend
and he stayed with us for like 5 days
all because on the phone I was like yeah
you know so now I don't say those things
anymore if I don't mean it I try not say
why that sounds like an amazing
experience it sounds awesome well it was
only no it could have been it could have
been bad lemonade out of lemons
situation for you um well it was it it
could have been horrible what was the
other one you had two was it thasos
thaso yeah so thaso was his company that
was buying up all the uh buying it was a
rollup an aggregator of Amazon Amazon
Brands Amazon one of the fastest growing
startups ever I think they went from
zero to a billion dollars in market cap
or valuation in like 12 months and tons
of Revenue and then tons of copycats
because everyone was like oh thrasio one
of the fastest growing startups in the
world we're GNA repeat this and um and
we had friends who did it too some of
our friends went and did the same thing
where they bought a bunch of Amazon
businesses may they rest in peace uh but
it didn't work right that the the
problem so you know I I remember calling
Andrew Wilkinson and I was like yeah
what do you think about the thrasio
stuff and I was like I was like I kind
of get it cuz you know they're doing uh
you know like roll I think rollups in
general are just like a a really nice
blueprint for a business this rollup
kind of makes sense Andrew had done a
semi rollup with uh Shopify apps and so
I was like do you see this as like you
know a really good opportunity what do
you think and he goes I think they're
picking up pennies in front of a steam
roller and I had never heard that before
but I guess that's a phrase like a like
a Charlie wonger type phrase if Andrew
says anything interesting it most likely
came from Charlie Munger that's his
hero uh and Charlie is like has
wonderful phrases so most of the stuff
most of the wisdom he has is from
Charlie monger and I go what do you mean
and he's like it's like picking up
pennies in front of a steamroller like
you know you're going to pick them up
you're picking up these little kind of
like what seems like these little cheat
free cheap assets and you think it's all
going well until you get completely run
over and if you fast forward till today
that's pretty much exactly what played
out these guys bought up a bunch of
businesses they rolled up what looked
like a lot of
Revenue and then they got run over and
at the time we did an
episode and the things we had said were
basically um so I basically took
Andrew's point of view and I was like
that does feel more right than the other
way and I said well what what could be
the problems and I was like basically
the FBA businesses are not very durable
so if you're going to do a rollup you
kind of want durability to be one of the
highest characteristics like normally in
business we think growth is the best
thing but actually when you're buying
businesses it's more about not being
wrong than it is about everything going
right and so you want durability when
you're rolling these up they bought
trash they bought like they would buy
like um um one of the Thousand vendors
on Amazon selling Chinese dog leashes
for $25 you know what I mean like they I
think they bought trash so like you know
Amazon uh is not durable for many
reasons number one uh the r you know
like the your your spot in the rankings
for these commodity products really
matters and like it's a constant battle
to keep to to get your ranking to stay
high which includes things like people
going and leaving fake reviews on your
thing so that your account gets taken
down like oh let me just spam you with
reviews so that Amazon detects you and
then delists you right that's [__] like
that or copycats or people who pay more
or whatever then there's Amazon
themselves launching Basics so for every
good category Amazon's like cool here's
the Amazon basic I know what do you know
it's at the top right like that was also
happening then there was the last thing
that's sort of the death blow which is
Andrew at tiny they sort of believe what
I think a few other of these like hold
code types believe which is that
synergies are massively overrated that
like it's very easy to talk yourself
into we're going to buy these five
companies and then Synergy and it's like
what Synergy it's like um we're going to
centralize the back office and we're
going to uh cross promote with each
other it's like no actually none of
these Brands had enough brand love for
you to cross promote anything you nobody
trusted you um the synergies in the back
office actually just turned into like a
bunch of people not really watching what
was going on in these individual
businesses the way they were when it was
just one person owning them so what's
the update on them so thrat is basically
dead um it's I don't know I don't know
exactly what the stage is is it it's
fire sale bankruptcy but it's dead and
so are all of the aggregators and so now
there's like the opposite phenomenon
there's like a d loing and which is
actually probably a better opportunity
to go pick the best 10 assets from all
these aggregators who are completely
underwater and they just have to you
know basically get rid of all these
assets and so um yeah tho and all the
thio copycats did not work out all right
I'll tell you one that we uh I wasn't
exactly right and the times that this
turned out to be true it didn't play out
how I thought it was going to so some
something that I talked to you about I
think since 2019 2020 was privacy so if
you look back on some of our episodes
when we were still in the old office so
this was
2019 I had this Insight from the founder
of Pandora so Pandora is the music
service the founder one time told me he
was like yeah like Mo many of our users
are like middle of America like dentists
who like have Pandora playing in the
background and what we've noticed about
them is they sometimes won't sign up
because they don't want to click the
link that says they agree to our terms
and services and our privacy statements
and to me that meant the average Joe
cares more about privacy than a lot of
people think at the time 2019 privacy
wasn't that big of a thing where you you
just click yes no matter what I think
that that and and so I predicted there's
going to be a lot of businesses that are
going to be created on top of that
another example that I had was duck duck
goo duck ducko is a privacy search
engine that doesn't like track you in
the same way Google does their searches
have gone up like crazy and the business
has gone on to raise 100 $ million of
which most of it I believe was a
secondary sale so they're quietly
killing it but I thought that this was
going to be more popular than it has
been it's kind of gotten popular because
Tik Tok uh so I think in Minnesota it is
or uh Montana it is uh they have banned
or trying to ban Tik Tok for privacy
reasons they're mostly doing it because
they don't like China not because
necessarily so this is where I was wrong
they're doing it for the Chinese purpose
not exactly the Privacy purpose but I
thought that this was by now going to be
a lot more popular than it is it's
slowly growing but we don't care if you
give up all your data but you better
give it up to an American company yeah
you better give it up to us yeah so that
has that we didn't I didn't nail that
yet I but I'm still I'm still holding
out but it I thought by now it would
have picked up a little bit but it
hasn't so I'm I'm going to give you one
that uh we got right and wrong at the
same time meaning we did an episode back
in 2020 July of 2020 Co has been like
raging for 3 months and we do an episode
called is gpt3 the next big thing
episode number 94 we're like in 500 now
this is
94 and we had gotten access to this tool
called gpt3 which at the time you had to
like get an API key to to you borrow
that you to get a friend to get you an
invite to get G and it wasn't that good
it was okay we were pretty stunned by it
mostly because we're 12-year-olds and we
like made it write like a rap song in
the form of cardi for us and we were
like this is hilarious this is amazing
it just wrote a rap like this rap is
actually good I I said write a rap by
cardi B and the title of the rap was
walk that plank and it was a very long
it was like it had Rhymes as if cardi B
was saying it it was very very we were
both so impressed and we were like this
is amazing and we were we were basically
like hey this is super cool uh blah blah
and we so we correctly back in July 2020
before chat GB T became the fastest
growing product of all time before open
AI became a hundred billion doll company
before AI was the was the trend we said
we released an episode that the title is
gpt3 the next big thing answer was yes
however I count this as an L why because
we just giggled about the rap lyrics and
didn't do [__] else we didn't do
anything about of it you know the move
the the optimal move was drop everything
and go work for open AI the second optim
move what you said you said in one of
the episodes you said if I'm smart I
should drop everything and go work in
that area and I'm not smart turns out
right then I proved to myself that I was
not smart I could have there was a
hundred ways to make a $100 million with
this I could have started a company
using gpt3 as the the backbone which the
guys from Jasper did they were like oh
let's use this to help marketers write
blog posts write tweet storms write uh
captions write anything that story needs
to play out still though though yeah but
they built a company that like got to
one of the fastest growing companies
I've ever seen like getting AR over $50
millionar in one year is like insane and
so could have started a company could
have gone and worked for open AI could
have invested in the open AI spinouts
like anthropic which is now a 20 billion
company or you know name the go through
the list could have um what else could I
have done I could have just yeah so
between investing starting a company or
joining a company there was a lot of
different ways
to capitalize on that opportunity that
we
identified but I didn't and I think this
has happened you know many times where
you sort of like you the opport the
elephant in the room is the opportunity
and you just sort of like oh that's cool
there's an elephant over there versus
being like Oh my God wait stop
everything I'm doing and let me reassess
what I'm doing in order to what's this
analogy you kill the elephant are you
going to kill theant look look you know
how it is with analogies on the
Fly sometimes you got to weave two and
two
together do kill the we got to kill
sometimes the elephant needs to strike
while the Iron's hot and now you got an
elephant that's striking iron right like
we don't know the elephants in Rome my
friend it's like that Michael Scott that
Michael Scott episode of The Office
where he's like sometimes I just start a
sentence and I have no idea where it's
gonna
go that's podcasting for you okay so let
me preface this I one of the things I
like to take pride in is either hiring
people before they get like uh before
they kind of reach their the the
Pinnacle of the career I also like this
on the podcast when we find interesting
people and we talk about them a lot of
times they're still popular but we got
them we got them before the curve one of
them was Andrew huberman we interviewed
Andrew huberman I forget exactly when
but when I remember when he interviewed
us he was just using his airpod
headphones looking at his laptop like it
looked like he was in a like a bathroom
or something like he like like as if he
was like ran to like some room you know
he wasn't like a big deal so that one
was a cool one so I got somebody here
that this is all you so you come on the
episode one day and you go you know this
guy Brian Johnson and I'm like nah not
really you're like you know venmo I'm
like yeah of course you're like well
it's owned by a company called brain
tree you know brain tree I'm like kind
vaguely payments company something and
you go listen to this guy's story so
this guy's story is basically Brian
Johnson I'm not going to do his whole
life story but like interesting kind of
early on door to door sales type of guy
ends up creating a tech company brain
tree buys venmo sells brain tree to
PayPal for like 700 $800 million creates
this like neurolink type of thing this
brain reader you're like but forget all
that I'm like forget all that that was a
lot that was amazing you're like forget
all of it go to this website blueprint.
Brian johnson.com and I go and it's like
size six font it looks like I'm reading
from a like a textbook and you're like
this guy is measuring every part of his
body every single organ um he is
measuring it and then he is optimizing
it he's doing crazy [__] and look at
this he's been doing this for like a
year and I had never heard of this most
people had never heard of this Brian
Johnson now I would say like I think
he's kind of tipped where like actually
in the tech industry everybody knows
about
him some mainstream people they'll
they'll call him the guy who's trying
not to die or something like that yeah
oh that guy yeah I've seen him he looks
weird right like there like the like cuz
I bring him up in like every
conversation I could find an excuse to
cuz he's fascinating and people are like
that's C oh I don't I just don't feel
like that's going to work right it's
like a very polarizing thing but you
found this early and you were watching
him you were like talking about it then
we got him on the Pod
earlier and we're about to release new
another episode I went to his house we
recorded another one but like I feel
like you spotted this was your a uber
Angel investment right you spotted Brian
Johnson way before anybody else was
really paying attention to him let me
explain the story it's been long enough
I can tell the story finally here's how
I found out about Brian I I can't name
names I have a friend that was going on
a first date with this lady he had just
met and he goes hey Sam I'm going to
take this lady she seems awesome I going
to take her on a first date I'm going to
take her I have a little plane I want to
take her up in the plane and we're going
to fly around F1 you know F1 was in
Austin we're going to go above the
stadium it's going to be an ordeal would
you and Sarah like to come on this
double date I would love it if you'd
come we said yeah sure Sarah gets sick
and I text him I go hey man Sarah's not
in anymore but I'll still go and
so I go
I third wheel on this date and we go on
this date and she's a lovely woman
whatever and she it wasn't trying to be
cool but I was trying to Hype up my
buddy and I goes hey lady have you uh
you ever been in a plane on a first date
like this is pretty cool she wasn't
trying to damp the mood or you know like
rub it in this guy's face but she goes
oh yeah you know this other guy used to
dated he he liked to fly and we're like
huh so we asked a few more questions and
we're like what does he fly and she
named some jet that's like a 40 billion
or $40 million Jet and we're like what
and she's and and then she says
something like yeah but he likes to fly
at himself but he has a staff and we're
like who the hell is this guy and so I
Google it like who this person is and
that's how I find Brian it was she used
to date him and that's how I find out
about him I just start googling and I
come across blueprint that he just
launched a few weeks prior and I'm like
right this guy's amazing that's how I
found Brian
Johnson
how did that date go though it didn't
work ious decision by you to join the
date I joined the date dude it's them
it's them two in the front two seats and
me in the
back and I have that head but I'm like
putting my hands over the like hey guys
like it was so
funny I had never been up in a blade
like that and I was like I'm passing
this up can I still go
and I was pipping him up the whole time
I was like hey guy have you told lady uh
about that one time you did this amazing
thing but you're doing it through the
plain headset thing which is like you
have to yell yeah but I'm still lead
enough like hey how about
the yeah
like did you tell her about the time
that you paid for everyone's dinner it
was $2,000 Roger yeah I'm like I'm
trying to like pimp him up while I'm
wearing this headset
you're like pointing out like hey we
could go there next week yeah was like
hey uh guy did you tell uh lady about
the time that you had the uh box seats
at the F1 and you took all of your
friends cuz you're so
nice yeah it was like that type of thing
it didn't work out though I tried my
best guy I'm sorry you know who you are
if you're listening to this that's uh
that's hilarious you um you had a couple
more on here I don't know if you have
time but you had a couple more in here
that that looked kind of interesting so
you had uh do paid communities and then
what's this inertia one let's do inertia
okay so you this was you you you talk a
lot uh that's no surprise but every once
in while you say something that's pretty
profound one of the profound things that
you said it's stuck with me this was in
2021 March of
2021 you had this episode uh where you
it's just called inertia I believe and
you said um inertia explains like uh
inary explains why 90% of people are
doing what they're doing in my life I've
had moments where I realized inertia is
a [__] inertia is the reason why I'm
doing these things not be not actually
because I want to but because of inertia
and often times I've got to check myself
and ask myself am I'm really doing the
right things and I think that you were
referring to a business that you had
previously sold where it wasn't doing
that well and you're like do I even
believe this is a big opportunity would
I even be doing this if I weren't
already doing it would I've hired these
same people would I work with these same
people the answer uh at the time was
hell no and that's when you decided to
get out so my question is he a no
question comment that was good that was
a really good Insight but question
number
two you've since sold a business so you
started and sold a business I think post
this comment yep do you still you like
do you still think about inertia all the
time and by the way this U this came to
about inertia yeah it's like the Roman
Empire for some guys for me it's inertia
um this happened because I had a come to
Jesus moment I uh I was with our buddy
suie and we went we used to go in San
Francisco if you drive like 30 minutes
down uh South out of San Francisco
there's these like casinos that are like
half casinos yeah so we go down there
and uh we're hanging out we're playing
we're having a good time at the end of
the night he's like
um he's like so why are you he's like so
I don't get what you're doing and I go
like Casino what are you talking about
he's like no no no this whole thing you
were because I was at Monkey Inferno at
the time and to the outside what I was
doing was the greatest job ever if
anybody had ever seen you've seen our
office at Monkey Inferno it was
literally the nicest office you have
ever been to in your life I called it a
Billionaire's playground is what it was
and that's what it was he literally
built his a billionaire literally built
his dream office and we just got to use
it there's a chef every day and there's
a gym and there's a but it's like for
only the 15 people that we were there it
was a and you had 20 or 15 you had 20 or
15 Engineers who are paid really nicely
and you could just do whatever you want
and the job was Sean you get to come up
with any IDE you want here's a team of
super talented Engineers to build them
and designers here's the funding you
never have to go raise
funding you get paid salary and you own
the equity um you can by the way you
don't even want to do you don't want to
focus on one go ahead do four at a time
build four time you have enough
resources go ahead do everything right
and I'm 25 years old when he 24 years
old when he names me CEO and at 24 that
was the greatest opportunity the
greatest experience ever at 25
incredible opport
then I was 29 and I was still doing the
same thing except
for now the pressure of like succeeding
like at the beginning was like dude this
is going to be awesome we're going to we
have so many shots on goal we're going
to do it then we took a lot of shots on
goal and we made some good things happen
but no big huge win which is what we
were all going for and by the end we
were really trying to like force a
square peg into a round hole it just
wasn't working but our mandate was like
build the next Twitter build the next
Snapchat it's like dude that's really
[__] hard to do but like okay we're
going to keep trying and so I got this
talented team in this beautiful office
I'm CEO I'm getting paid well I got
Equity I got everything you would want
and here's my best friend the guy looked
up to saying what the hell are you doing
and I was like he's looking at me like
I'm a junkie like dude what are you
doing with your life and I'm like what
are you talking about this is amazing of
course this is amazing right and he's
like you told me how much money you made
back then and I think it was like low
six figures like over it was over
100,000 but less than $200,000 and I
remember when you told me that I was
like making 160 at the time yeah I was
like that's the most money of anyone I
know like you have
$100,000 like that it was huge I
remember you told me that M that amount
and I was like you're so it was huge to
me too I was like this is amazing then
and then I was like if any of these
ideas hit this is great so he he's
talking to me he's just like I feel he's
like I feel like you're just doing the
same thing over and over again and not
getting a result you want and I was like
he's he basically asked me a very simple
question he's like you know um if you
weren't already working on this project
if I just took the project away I if
tomorrow this whole company had to fold
because oh they forgot to pay their
bills and whatever this folded tomorrow
would you pick up the phone would you
call these same people and say hey we're
still doing this idea right that's the
biggest idea we could possibly think of
it's the one we must do would you call
these same people to work on the same
idea and my answer was yes the same
people hell no not the same idea he's
like he's and and I was like that's kind
of a shitty realization to have it's
like I was like am I an idiot and he's
like no he's like this is common he's
like inertia is a [__] and he's like
almost all of us are just doing what
we're doing because we were already
doing it and like this this even happens
with Investments after we got acquired I
got a bunch of Amazon stock and so my
portfolio was like super skewed towards
Amazon I was you know all of a sudden
here's millions of dollars of Amazon
stock okay if if you had just given me
the millions of dollars I wouldn't have
put all of it into Amazon only but
because it was already there I was like
should I sell Amazon I don't know it's a
good company right it's like because it
was already there my decision was
totally different than if I had just
Rewritten the the decision from scratch
saying if I if I just had this money
today is this exactly how I would
allocate it it the same thing happens in
your portfolio as happens in the time of
your life like would I would I allocate
my energy and my talents to this project
or am I just doing it because I've been
doing it if I just doing it because
that's what I'm already doing and I
think the sad answer is that for most
people they're doing what they're doing
cuz they're already doing it it's not
the thing that if they had a blank slate
today they would just go back and
recreate this that's the same argument
my wife gave to me about selling HubSpot
stock I've not sold any and she was like
well would you buy this stock anyway my
argument was well first of all I I do
like the company but do I like it enough
to have that much of my portfolio in it
I I don't know but my argument is like
well but I don't want to pay taxes and
frankly I'm not sure if that's a good
argument or not um but I I am a victim
of it as well yeah yeah of course right
there's nuances to some of these things
but like that same principle just
applies to a lot of parts of your life a
lot of people are in relationships they
don't want to be in because they're
already in the relationship they're in
jobs they don't want to be in because
they're they're in it and uh and I just
kind of had this like it was 2: a.m and
I'm in this Chinese casino and my friend
is telling me this thing and I remember
we drove to our office a badge in at
like 2:30 in the morning we go to the
Whiteboard and we say we're going to
spend the next hour trying to figure out
if we can actually make this company
work and if at the end of this hour we
don't look at a plan on this whiteboard
that we feel is like this is going to
work like I believe that this is worth a
shot then I'm going to sell this company
like tomorrow I'm just going to get out
of this company and then at the end of
that hour we looked at it we were like
this is I mean these are all just like
random long shots that like we can't sit
here and say we have a ton of conviction
in and then like the next day I talked
to our main investor I said I think it's
time to to shake it up like I need to
shake up something in my life this is
all beautiful this is amazing I can't
believe you gave me this experience but
like I don't want this anymore Let's
either sell the company or you should
replace me or something something's got
to change I can't unhear what I heard
last night and uh I have a lot of flaws
but the one good thing I have is that
once I hear the truth I just act on it
like I just agree that like I've heard
the truth now and that's it there's no
going back from that uh whereas I think
some people will see or hear the truth
and then they'll go into denial or
they'll delay and I don't do denial or
delay that's a good one um yeah I always
um I thought that that line inertia is a
[__] I I remember that one so I had to
bring that one up um maybe the last one
is paid communities so I've been
interested there's a if you listen
closely over the last 550 episodes
there's like two to three things that
I've like have been obsessed about and I
knew I was going to act on one of them I
acted on one of them it's a paid
community so by the way can you say the
two or three what are the what what
would be the two or three I I uh helping
people find jobs so I call it job boards
it's beyond that but I've always been
fascinated by that um and then creating
um like um somewhat related but I was
I've always been fascinated by the
trucking industry or other like blue
collar essential jobs that aren't don't
have a lot of technology or software in
order to help them be more efficient um
so th those are like two or three things
that I've always really liked and then
of course B2B media companies and
database and research businesses um but
the other one that I really loved was
paid communities and if you listen
closely starting in 2020 I did a lot of
breakdowns on different paid communities
so I mentioned tiger 21 vistage which uh
has since sold so I I talked about
vistage a lot of people didn't know what
vistage is it's like um similar to what
Hampton does similar to YPO does but the
target market is uh CEOs and business
owners of like plumbing companies uh in
the in middle of America doesn't sound
that huge but it has since sold for
about $1.8 billion I think about 8 or 10
months ago it was doing now it's doing
close to $500 million a year in sales
very
profitable and so I talked about paid
communities and I talked about tiger 21
a few other ones here's the I I made a
list of pros and cons back in 2020 so
this was March 2020 and I'll tell you if
I think the pros and cons are true since
I'm now run Hampton for about one year
so Pros a paid paid communities they can
grow quickly they seemed fun to run if
you're interested in the topic you don't
need a lot of money to start them they
definitely seem profitable um and then
the cons were a lot of times they don't
scale that well I think churn could be
pretty pretty high uh and those were
like my two main cons so the truth is is
that they can grow quickly but you don't
want them to grow quick quickly you want
them to grow slowly so I was a little
bit wrong about that can you start them
with zero money zero dollar yes I
started Hampton with no money uh we
didn't even buy a website or domain name
um can they be very profitable yes the
answer is yes they can
um what I got wrong or didn't mention
was how meticulous you have to be about
growth and they can get big but they
just take longer and that's okay because
I think if they take longer usually not
always if something takes longer to grow
maybe that means that it's going to die
it has is less likely to die quickly
example thoros grew quickly probably
he's going to die very quickly there's a
lot of examples of that and so it has in
fact proven to be a big business or can
be a big business it's harder to grow
than I thought but not because of demand
but because you don't want it to grow
quickly you need it to grow slowly you
to be really thoughtful so I
underestimated how challenging that is
um but I did a lot of the work in front
of people I I I would have thought that
someone was going to launch this I even
interviewed uh the funny thing is the
funny thing is you you invited a couple
of other paid Community CEOs on the Pod
as guests asked them a 100 questions and
then took their lunch and I just find
that to be an incredible story
that I look forward to telling uh as
this plays out I I need it to work uh I
need to work first at the time you had a
community called Club LTV which was an
Ecom Community I think it was making
$100,000 a month pretty much right away
I think you actually that name is
wonderful it was uh it was free I didn't
charge for it um but it was like invite
only like I basically that was I was
running an e-commerce business but I'm
part-time in it and I've never done
e-commerce before
and so I have a strategy of like if I'm
going to do something that I don't know
how to do there are hacks to learn
faster one of the hacks is surround
yourself with other people who are doing
that playing the same game at one to two
levels above where you're playing it
meaning they're one to Two Notch just
better at it than you are and further
along than you are and so when we wanted
to grow big on on Twitter I think both
of us had a similar idea we created a
group a text message group called the
100K club and we invited six people who
all had that same goal and then we all
talked in there about initially like
stuff we were doing to make that happen
then we all just became friends but like
immersion into a small Club of people
who play the same or playing the same
game at a one or two Notch higher level
than you is one of the one of the hacks
to get better at something faster and so
Club LTV was cool if I just create a
curated group of awesome e-commerce
owners I'm going to learn a bunch of
[__] that I need to know to make my own
thing successful so I'm not even
charging these people um because I don't
need to make money off this I want the
information I actually wanted the
network from it and that's exactly what
I got out of it but you made money
through advertising um and you have
sponsors and that model actually works
so there's a company called Aventa who
does this but they did it with like
Chief Information officers so these are
like Fortune 500 and they were making um
they they sold for 17 times profit for
$250 million so they're making I think
50 million in revenue and then whatever
that profit is I can't do that math um
but they s so model that you had it
works the downside which I don't think
you you knew getting into it
logistically there's it's it's a very
operationally heavy business it's very
very challenging uh it's not Ecom is
also operationally heavy but it's more
so like there's like three or four
things that you have to nail with people
there's like way more things there's
like people's feelings that you have to
like account for and it's a little bit
more of an art and it's actually quite
challenging to hire uh help for that
type of business but you are on to
something and I actually think Club that
one was a business that could have
totally worked uh me and Ben I remember
we just had a conversation like hey do
we want to actually turn this into a
business it can it'll work it would be
profitable we just saw better
opportunities for ourselves uh but like
that's one where if I knew the right
person I would have totally just handed
over clv CL TV and be like you're the
operator of this now uh there's a clear
path to make this a business there's
like one called e-commerce fuel that's
out there that's kind of like the which
I love older version of this I was
paying
subscriber really why why you didn't do
I just thought it was awesome uh Andrew
the guy who started it I used to read
his blog and I thought it was sick it
was $300 a year I think he listens to
the pot I and I talked to him every once
in a while I just thought it was cool I
thought e-commerce F was great in fact I
was a paying member in Moy Ali this very
rich successful guy sorry Moyes I'm
going to blow your cover he used to use
my account because he didn't want to pay
$300 a year to he he would use my we
would share a password uh so like it's
pretty funny but I lik e-commerce I
thought it was great it's still a thing
and he limits it to 3,000 people I think
right uh something like that I I don't I
I don't actually use it cuz it's a forum
and I don't really love like forums and
there's like Live Events or whatever I I
like the way we did it with Club LTV I
thought that was more more fun and
easier just easier to to like actually
participate in um so anyways I thought
that uh yeah that that definitely could
have been a business uh just you know
you got to pick and choose opportunities
so long story short uh what what do you
think is the what's your takeaway from
this so like what do you uh okay we made
a BN bunch of predictions we go back we
look we see what we were right about
what we were wrong about what's your to
the Chris Barling question that I love
what's the right lesson to learn out of
this the right lesson to learn there's a
few the number one is we we make money
talking about this stuff and that's
great you could say we make a great
living doing
that I feel like a puss for not acting
on some of these things I guess I acted
on one but like there's been five or 10
or 20 things where you've told me and
I'm like that's cool I should go in on
that mainly there's only been three
things that I've gone in on which is trt
but like [__] we talked about open AI
like I we should have put our money I
think you have in a few cases but I
should have put my money where my mouth
was a little bit more so that's one
lesson which is predictions aren't that
easy or aren't that terribly hard Having
the courage in them is
hard uh mine is the exact same thing
which is that the predictions that
matter are the ones where
you notice something early before
everybody notices it but then you like
that's you know it it's kind of cliche
right ideas are kind of cheap and exuse
everything no no the idea is actually
quite valuable however it's potential
energy you got to turn the potential
energy into kinetic energy how do you do
that through like motion right so it's
like chasing it down and actually doing
something with it is um is where all the
value gets created and me and Ben have
actually figured out a little bit of a
better way to do this both through like
actually having like vehicles to invest
in these things but also we just
continually stop and ask ourselves like
I think in the last six months there's
probably been two or three times where
we say what's the thing that we see
right now that three four you know three
years from now we're going to be like
dude we talked about that that was in
front of our face why didn't we just go
and meet the guy why didn't we go and
invest in the thing why didn't we start
one whatever it is right and so by
asking that question regularly like
what's the thing that's actually hidden
in plain sight right now for us um I
think I'm going to like turn that dial
from like uh missing a bunch of these
opportunities to taking advantage of
them we should do a whole episode on
what those things are yeah yeah I will I
I'll tell you the way I learned that by
the way was I met this guy Anam Myra and
Anam Myra came to my office and he was
the first product manager at Twitter and
I was like tell me what it was like back
then he's like well there was like I
don't know 12 people in the company uh I
join you know 15 people something like
that I join and I was like was it
obvious at the time that like Twitter
was going to become Twitter he's like no
no no not at all like Twitter was kind
of interesting but looked pretty
frivolous and useless people were
texting out like what they were eating
there was no app at the time it just you
just texted this number like 44444 or
whatever like whatever you were having
for lunch and in silica Valley people
were like kind of having fun with it a
little bit but it didn't seem like a
serious like he's like I had like job
offers from Microsoft or whatever like I
had serious opportunities and then here
was this like Twitter thing even the
name sounded
frivolous and he's like um but I had
learned one important lesson which is
that whenever you see like a phenomenon
of behavior meaning you see people
acting in a way that seems strange weird
or inexplicable or irrational the
natural reaction is to just ride it off
be like I don't know those are weirdos
that that makes no sense idiots and move
on and he's like what I've learned is
now he's a VC and he's like as a VC and
as at the time and as like thank God in
my career I I realized that which was
when you real when you see that weird
behavior that you don't understand the
thing is not to the thing not to do is
label it and write it off it's to lean
in and try to understand it he's like so
I saw that people were like like why
would you text out what you're eating
right now like what do you why and why
do why do you like to see what other
people are saying in that same way like
that seems completely like strange
Behavior but people are doing it he's
like anytime you see strange behavior
and people doing it like that's usually
the the in that's what a amazing
opportunity actually looks like and
since he told me that I then saw that
many times over like we got acquired by
twitch I remember in college walking
into my the dorm room the guy next to me
who who lived next to me and he was
watching a like a replay of someone
playing a Starcraft tournament and I was
like you are King dork not only is
StarCraft on your screen right now you
are not even playing you are watching
some guy in Korea play this game that is
literally like the dorkiest dumbest
thing I didn't and I literally made fun
of him for it for like a year later when
we got Acquired and he's like oh you're
head of Esports at twitch now he was
like uh he literally was like you [__]
he called me and he was like you used to
make fun of me for this and I was like
dude I agree I was totally dumb and
wrong I should have way I I don't even
play games but I watch people on YouTube
playing yeah and I was like I should
have leaned in why would somebody do
this behavior that seems completely
irrational why would somebody watch
someone else play video games on the
other side of the earth through this
Replay that he had to download at the
time there was no twitch at the time
it's like he had to download this thing
off the server for eight hours and then
watch it at night and I was like weird I
don't want to hear it and then of course
you know so missing that five times has
taught me like lean into that like and I
just remember the open a example by the
way Sam Alman president of YC right he
is he had the best job in Silicon Valley
president of YC was the best job of Sil
in Silicon Valley at the time YC is
probably the most like value generative
company at the time uh or like
organization he's the president he got
picked over anybody else and he left to
go join an AI
nonprofit I like what yeah like
something something's up these
billionaires are putting H hundred
million dollars into this AI research
company this nonprofit why would they do
that and again I was just like weird Sam
doing a weird inexplicable thing instead
I should have been like hey the smartest
guy in Silicon Valley just left the most
prestigious job in Silicon Valley to do
this thing that sounds sort of like
strange to me lean in and uh yeah that's
the lesson I would share at my takeaway
of this whole thing let me wrap up with
one quick thing I forgot I should have
said this earlier but we did this
episode about this guy I think he was in
India
and we called him in and he like talked
to us without his video on and I found
him because he had this website called
Uber Pro I think it was called Uber
dopro and I've Googled his name I
Googled his name last night I can't find
him anywhere online oh he's gone I can't
find him anywhere and if anyone can find
him please do this this would be amazing
I want to see what he's up to now he was
23 years old or even younger and what I
did was I gave him $1,000 and he gave me
$10,000 in Uber credit and for like
years I took an Uber black everywhere
because what he did was I think this is
how it worked what he did was he found
all of these Indian kids that were like
in his town and when you rode Uber for
the very first time and you referred
people you got $25 in free credit and
somehow he made it so he could convince
all these kids to take a free Uber to
get $25 in credit and to continually
refer themselves I also think he ranked
really high on Google for Uber discount
code or Uber promo code and so he
accumulated
millions of dollars of uber credit and
you could buy the Uber credit from him
for 10 cents or 20 cents on the dollar
and I found this website and I was like
I'm doing this and I bought I think
$1,000 worth of uber credit and I and
then you have to change your iPhone from
America to malova your Uber account has
to be in malova and that was this
loophole and he was making a lot of
money doing it for an Indian a guy in
India he was making thousands of dollars
a month which I think in the pot he's
like yeah this is so much money I think
he was making 30 grand a month and I
always I've always wondered what is that
kid up to I wanted to know where I
remember having him on he was
fascinating he was he was fascinated
that was a great Arbitrage that the guy
uh you know had architected for himself
very I don't know if it's illegal but
definitely against the rules
questionably unethical but when you see
things like that they're going somewhere
and I've always wanted to know what
happened to that guy I want to leave you
with two of the kind of you know I
talked about like why am I hearing about
this three times don't just ignore this
like I'm training my brain to not ignore
these signals now I'll give you two of
them for people who made it this far in
the episode These are the gem this is
the gem now uh this is the part where
you're like holy [__] I can't believe
they saved this for the end which is
basically the two trends that I see
right now that
are strangely big go to go to
character. and pull up how much traffic
you see that that website has oh my God
I would have thought like 10,000 a month
and what's the real number oh my God
so 200
million exactly
200 million what this like you could go
to the Wall Street Journal it won't have
200 million you could go to New York
Times it's not gonna have 200 million
this is no no media site has that and it
has an average visit duration of 33
minutes it's beta. character. okay so
I've been on this talking about I've
been talking about Ai and I've been
talking about like only fans and this
like kind of sometimes the crossover
between Ai and like this like AI only
fans thing and I'm looking at investment
opportunities in the space there are so
many companies that are doing this like
chat with a AI type of thing replica
character AI whatever and they never
thought that would be a thing they all
have ludicrous traffic we called it by
the way we talked about replica like a
year ago um girlfriends a i virtual
girlfriends exactly and that's a lot
that's a lot of how people use this
character AI thing like they kind of
chat with uh the chat I think goes into
the gray area a little bit um I mean
it's a lot of like smart people like
Einstein but but the the top person is
Ariana Grande and Billy ish and then
like some K-pop lady like there's that
probably a a weird people being willing
to chat with AI for a really long time
so easy to write off as weird loser but
it's it's my friend watching Starcraft
tournaments in the room next door right
dork King dork
Behavior I will not make that mistake
again this is this is definitely
something I don't think that these
companies necessarily are the winners
but like you know every every product
there's kind of like the wave one of
attempts wave two of attempts wave three
and then finally there's like the last
mover right the the last mover who
actually Nails it and builds a full-on
product around this and so there's
something in this space that's like
ranges from companionship to um naughty
chat that like with AI that's going to
be massive because the numbers are off
the charts the behavior of this strange
thing is off the charts okay that's one
second one which is less crazy is um
there's a bunch of really smart people
that are now have a new business
strategy and their business strategy is
to buy wounded
unicorns and so heard it once heard it
twice heard it three times first heard
this from Andrew Wilkinson Andrew
Wilkinson he he called me back a couple
years ago I was living in my old house
San Francisco and he I remember him
telling me you know what I would do if I
was you is I would find one of these uh
startups that's raised Venture Capital
but is not going to become a billion-
dollar company but they got to 5 million
in Revenue 10 million in revenue and you
could buy these for cheap because they
don't have a they can't raise their next
round and there's no way out and so
there's not really like a a good exit
market for that group and those people
don't want to like fire a bunch of the
engineers stop paying high prices for
their San Francisco office space and
like become profitable they could in
theory but they're just not going to eat
[__] in order to do that they're just
going to shut it down return investor
money sell the assets to whoever and
they're going to go start their next
company or go get a job he told me that
first he had then done that with a
company called meteor so medier was his
developer framework and I think he
bought a company that was doing like
five to seven million it was doing like
5 million plus in revenue for like one
ex revenue or I don't know it was like
some like ignore the multiple the exact
multiple I think I think they raised $30
million or something like that they had
raised a bunch of money it had customers
it had Revenue but it just wasn't going
to be the next big thing which is
venture capital is called become the
next big thing or bust and what he
realized was if they bust we can pick
some of these assets up so Andrew had
said it then um you hear other people
that are talking about this that are
doing this our friends Xavier and sea
they're doing this right now if you're
driving to San Francisco there is a
billboard with with their company that
says like whatever like there's never
too late for a second chance or
something it looks like honestly it
looks like a divorce lawyer cuz it's KJ
with her arms crossed and it says like
um you know there's always uh you know
there's always a second chance or
something like that and I don't know
what the Billard say they literally have
a billboard entering San Francis you
know like when you come in on whatever
the 101 it's like um uh it's right there
and it's basically saying you know like
don't just shut down your company sell
it to us so they're doing this Jeremy
gfin is like he came on invest like the
best and he was like yeah I think one of
the big opportunities right now is to do
this you hear this for five times from
smart
people like you got to be an idiot to
not realize that there's probably
something there and it's like it's not
you're hearing it from the news like you
got to know where you're hearing it from
you're not hearing it from the news or
like the hype cycle type of things it's
like you hear smart people mention these
things in kind of passing or these
opportunities but it's not consensus yet
and you realize like oh that's probably
one of these like what I call like you
know value spots or fat pitches so like
what are the big fat pitches that you
could go swing at you don't have to go
swing at it but like you should identify
that at any given time there's like a
couple of fat pitch opportunities that
you could be going for that's one of
them I want to learn more about it I
want to how do you find I mean I want to
know I've got questions like how do you
find them just run bro don't don't even
don't even think about it just keep
running hampon you already got your fat
pitch well um by the way love saying fat
pitch by the way just a fun fun phrase
to say yeah I agree uh it's a good one
it's a good one where'd you steal that
from T Teddy Williams Warren Buffett
who stole it from Ted
Williams who knows I know he said it in
his
biography I know hard to
say no I said it very easily um all
right that's the
[Music]
pod